[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today
in Washington D.C I'm Mitch welcome to
the Ramsey Show
thanks for having me how y'all doing
today better than we deserve what's up
so my wife and I recently went under
contract on a house and we're excited
but it's two people that have pretty
much adhered to a debt-free lifestyle
we're nervous about taking out a
mortgage on the property no real estate
is a great investment but we're nervous
to take out a chunk of our savings for
the cash to enclosed and even more
nervous about the monthly payment on the
mortgage should I press ahead and take
on that better hit pause and rethink
things
well it depends on what's giving you
pause about this is it because the
payment is a big portion of your income
every month I mean what percentage of
your income is it tapping into every
month so my wife and I do we do that 215
000 a year between the two of us and the
house the mortgage to get the house will
sold for 7.75 we're putting five percent
down so it's going to be a big check
more than 25 percent
of your take-home pay probably
that might be why you're feeling this
because at the end of the day right when
you have your mortgage you want it to
you want to feel good about it right you
want to know okay I can pay the mortgage
I also have plenty of uh spread here to
do everything else that I need to do
because let's let's just break down the
numbers here okay most people they're
wanting to put 10 some sort of giving
right at some point you're going to want
to put 15 aside for your investing and
that then you've got this 25 mortgage
payment you're already at 50 so if that
mortgage payment Creeps in you know 30
40 you're going to start feeling that
pinch very quickly and my guess is
that's probably where you're at how much
money you got in savings
uh between the two of us about ninety
thousand dollars
okay and you're putting most of that
down
uh we're putting about 56 000 of it down
and keeping a little bit left over just
for a rainy day okay and you have no
other debt
no zero debt except for student loans
but I haven't paid on those since the
pandemic
and I'm a federal employee so they're
going to be forgiven soon anyway
no they're not
there's not a program to forgive student
loans
that's actually working
what do you mean who told you you're
lonely I thought if you were if you were
a federal employee after a number of
years of federal service they actually
forgave your balance of your lungs I
think it's 10 or 15 years of federal
service yeah it's 10 years and so so far
97 of the people that have made
application for that have not gotten the
Forgiveness we literally ran the numbers
me and some folks who work here in
research Department ran the numbers on
that yesterday it's 1.97 percent
other people other people that apply
actually their forgiveness
I hate to say it how much is your
student loan debt
uh it's probably
80 to 100 000 between the two of us
all right um
well
you have signed a contract and so you're
in this deal unless you are not approved
for the mortgage so you will keep your
word I'll never tell people to break
their word but if we were to coach you
um before you got into all of this we
would tell you to become debt free
student loans and everything before you
purchased a home uh uh a government plan
to forgive your student loans is
um
statistically irrational it doesn't
occur and
um so we want you to clear I would want
you as a method best method of building
the best possible life with the most
wealth is to clear all debt including
student loans as soon as possible have
an emergency fund plus a down payment so
you would not be in a position to buy a
home today if you had come to us before
you were under contract now that you're
under contract make sure that the home
is a 15-year mortgage not that is no
more than 25 percent of your take-home
pay and take-home pay being not after
401K but just after taxes after taxes
and
um and are you putting money into your
401ks right now
yes yes I am okay in your situation if
you go ahead and close on the house or
if you don't stop that temporarily until
you get these student loans cleared
because the best thing you can do for
your future is to clear these student
loans as soon as possible
um and and then let's keep the home
payment on a 15-year fixed where it's no
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
after taxes not after health insurance
not after uh car payment coming out for
the credit union not after uh 401k and
all that but just after taxes what's
your take-home pay and is your payment
going to be more than that and um so
yeah
um that that's how we would tell you to
do it using what we call the baby steps
which has helped more people get out of
debt and become wealthy than any other
system so far right now in America
certainly more than 1.6 percent of the
people that attempt it well here's the
thing when he took out this when he made
an offer on this house we don't know if
he planned on getting a 15-year or a 30
year I sure hope he planned
on a 15 year he's going to be up a creek
without a paddle well I mean just it
probably doesn't state that in the
contract it just says to be approved for
financing yeah that's true and if you're
not approved for financing because you
say I will only do a 15-year then you
would be out of the deal and then you
would write a check and pay off your
student loans and you would rent for a
little while longer until you get your
self in a position to actually yeah
purchase
this is the problem folks it gets us
just so angry around here we can't
breathe because we love you guys we want
you to win
and when you believe lies about your
money yeah that cost you Decades of your
life
it it it disturbs us because we want you
to win and here's one of these lies just
very casually
as if as if it was just a stated known
fact oh well they'll get forgotten I
don't have to worry about those student
loans they're forgiven and and then to
come to find out they're not and it's a
lot of them too
1.6 of people get to the 10-year mark
under that program are actually getting
forgiveness yeah and then there's the
new 30-year Mo program which is going to
end up being worse only you will be 20
years further into yeah it's not good
meantime you've sat on this egg and sat
on this egg and sat on this egg and when
it hatches
it's a monster a monster in the egg it
wasn't a goose it was a monster
no Goose laying any golden eggs in there
a little a little goonie comes out
that's so true
and you know that's that's infuriates me
that the government has continued to
spread this crap and that people on
these hope Stealers on the internet
continue to spread this crap to the and
people believe it and when you believe
it when you believe a lie and you act on
a lie it always causes you to stub your
toe have a bloody nose and a black eye
it always causes that oh Bliss is hard
I'm so sorry for him yeah that's that's
tough I was talking to a reporter today
there's a guy that doesn't like that
right
I was talking to a reporter today and I
said to him I said everybody's
complaining about the interest rates in
the whole housing market oh it's so hard
to buy a house today but these are the
same people Dave who are fine with and
doing what this guy's doing what's I
only have 80 100 000 debt I'm fine with
keeping that there I'm like do you don't
see if you don't see how that's
affecting your ability to purchase a
home and have peace about it that's one
of the reasons this is all related
because even if the forgiveness is
hanging out the only way the forgiveness
if it did happen is if you continue to
make the payment uh-huh
putting the squeeze on the dadgum
budgets a hundred thousand dollar
student loan yeah that's where the
that's why you're feeling pinched you're
exactly right but even if even if you're
one of these people who says oh I'm
going to get the lowest payment possible
you're going to tell me that you're
going to move into a brand new 775
000 house
and that hundred thousand dollars of
student loans isn't gonna strangle you
with its presence every night yeah
oh there's a goonie you're sitting
there's a little monster in that egg
it's like when uh we've all been there
right you're you know somebody's coming
over to the house and your house is a
mess oh my my parents-in-law my
mother-in-law's coming over so you slide
everything in the closet real quick I
kind of charge the in-laws with you look
I don't know this
I maybe shouldn't make a metaphor where
where in-laws are the same as student
loans but you shove it all into the
closet and you think it's clean but you
know what's really in that closet and
you know it's got to get dealt with